first time in 609 days the yankees can
have a full capacity crowd here in the
bronx jameson tyonne gonna tow that slab
in the boogie down here
be his 13th start on the year you know
if you look at all the numbers there
they all look you know pretty decent
except for the era and the home runs
loriano now here's the o2
struck him out swinging high fastball
out of the zone two-way good start for
tyonne
and
in the corner if it's fair it's gone it
is and the ace take the lead
matt olson stays red hot with a second
zach home run to right field and it's
one nothing is in the first uh he likes
his fastball so does uh olson
especially one down the middle of play
you
that's unbelievable his 19th home run of
the year that's how hot matt olson is i
mean you make a mistake he doesn't miss
it
he has not missed any
in april may and now half of june james
caprilian making his seventh start of
the season seven start of his career
and you have to know that there is going
to be a ton of emotion coursing through
the veins of this man right now former
yankee draft pick former yankee first
rounder here's aaron judge the big kid
from linden
oh cabrillo got the call judge
not completely sold on it caprilian is
and it's a strikeout well that's all
right the only one
that sean murphy needs to get to buy in
on that is the home plate umpire and
that's exactly
what happened
torres 260 with three homers 23 rbis
and that right there that swing and that
pitch right there has a lot to do with
the ch the pitch to judge and the first
pitch to torres one away here's chapman
and the pitch
grounded the third
herscheller off balance throw and the
scoop by lemayo
completes the play
we're looking at this play i don't know
who made a better play was it urchella
or was it la mayhew at first base
very hard to make this throw going three
or four steps foul territory but a great
scoop by a scoop by le mayhew
in between or there that is a great play
one nothing the a's lead bottom of the
second inning here's john carlos stamp
0-2 pitch chase to high fastball and he
strikes out so three consecutive
strikeouts for caprilia and here's geo
urchella here's the o2 pitch now and
that's swung out of this there's the
high fastball that strikes him out what
a start to this game for caprilian five
batters four k's there's cannon bounce
one to short his first time up
line drive base hit center field
they're waving home alves anders the
throw is going to be just a little bit
late anders comes in to score canna
comes through it's two nothing gardner's
at first with chad here is dj and dj is
the tying run driven to right field and
deep going back canada on the track at
the wall see ya a two-run home run for
dj lemayo and we are tied up in two
more all over the play dj lemay this
wasn't just right over a you know a wall
scraper this ball shot 10 rows up but
great piece of hitting by lemayo all the
sudden guys dealing
boom two run homer two to two
moreland off second murphy up first
2-2 count on kemp at the plate
broken back looper toward first and it's
caught on the fly by lemayo and that'll
do it right now it's about weaving his
way through the lineup
second time
fastball outside corner and he has gone
to looking a half a dozen k's for
caprilian and here comes giancarlo
stanton
grounds that one to the right side right
to lowry
that's the second out here's geo
urchella
and he got him to chase her shella
strikes out for the second time
seven strikeouts do four innings for
caprilian
marcana leads off first base with one
out
waved at that one and loriano down on
strikes they are not going to let tyonne
face olsen again olson hit that long
home run in the first did strike out in
the third but they don't want tyon to
face him for a third time so they bring
in the left-hander peralta now here's
the 2-2
swung on and hit in the air to center
field in deep gardner back he's on the
track he's at the wall he makes the
catch
at the monument park wall he had no more
room and he made a little leap bottom of
the fifth the game is tied at two here
is odor to lead it up
high fly ball deep right center there it
goes see ya three two yankees
telling you what odor has watched reggie
jackson's old video tapes because when
he goes deep there is something about
his backflip
readjustment of the helmet and kind of
his jog that reminds me of reggie
jackson and this was a bomb
chad pinder is going to pinch it for
mitch moreland
swing and a miss
peralta
against pinder
and here's tony kemp pony camp right now
he's so hot he's not a guy these look to
pinch it for
kemp
right field and that baby's gone
tony kemp a three run homer and the a's
lead five to three
tony kemp once again comes through for
the athletics well short porch in a
yankee stadium
enough said capronian goes five and
two-thirds innings he pitched well
tonight seven strikeouts in just one
walk and only three hits allowed so he
comes out and he's going to watch you
sparrow petite faced giancarlo stanton
with a runner at third first pitch to
stamford
stamp hits one high in the air and he
just got underneath it so one pitch
and petite gets out of it so three and
two on olson first and second nobody out
here in the seventh
popped up
in field fly rule call and the catch is
made in foul territory what away
there's the 2-2
struck him out swinging that's the
strikeout they needed
second and third two outs are in the top
of the seventh inning and the a's lead
the yankees five to three
one two
strike three
lowry down looking please go to lou
trevino to try to save it here's the 2-1
pistic labor torres swung on a ground
ball left side right to short taken by
elvis and he flips to first for the out
quickly went away
big walk for stanton and that brings up
geo as a tying run
that one's hit hard
andrus steps on the bag flips to first
double play
so there it was archela just out in
front enough
and it was right to alva sandras
and he stepped on the bag and lucha vino
shuts the door